hey we'll look guys might what am i
doing you know what new year not for
that you guys know my name is at the
chair no let's just get into this so
this video I'm gonna keep really simple
there's no reason for this to be a long
video all I'm going to do is show off a
little project that I've been working on
it's gonna help me make more videos in
the future as well as test out certain
things inside OpenGL it's gonna be used
a lot in this channel for both the game
engine series and the OpenGL series and
it's very much a work in progress and
one of the things that I really want to
do this year is share more of what I
actually do with you guys so instead of
just kind of giving you the final
product and the finished product and
being like again this is my completed
code it took me like a lot of time to
actually perfect and this is all you see
the perfection the result at the end of
it I don't want to do that I know you
guys are not just interested in the
final kind of destination you're also
interested interested in the journey and
how the project kind of evolves over
time so that's why this year one of the
things that I want to do is for sure
release more unfinished stuff which is
cuz scary because I know that I'm gonna
get judged a lot for like certain code
by certain people and being like you
know what what do you do why are you
doing it this way everyone thinks
through code differently everyone works
on projects differently so I mean
there's this thing that I'm going to
show you here is the result of a couple
days of work it's not it's not like bad
by any means it's not something that I
would you know that I'm embarrassed to
share that's not the point the point is
that it's something that will naturally
evolve over time with help from the
community with help from kind of just as
I make each video and I realize hunt
that would be good my intention with
this is not just to release a final
product as I said it's more or less to
kind of be like here is kind of this
base and then let's build upon this base
so speaking of the base what is it what
have I done so a little bit of backstory
the OpenGL series is a series I have on
my channel where I teach OpenGL and
we're getting to the point where there
has to be some kind of I guess based
library based kind of library of
existing code upon which I can
demonstrate another concept and the game
engine series really requires this as
well because that's like a full-on game
engine so if I'm kind of if I want to do
batch rendering for example instead of
integrating it into the game engine I
want to integrate it into the OpenGL
series but to do that you know it's very
difficult to just open up a blank
project and then be like okay batch
rendering but first we have to set up
these billion things right and so what I
what I wanted to do and what that kind
of inspired was me creating a base
OpenGL library like just a bunch of
boilerplate code so that you can just
literally like download this repository
from github and then just like run the
script or whatever to generate all the
project files or open the solution and
then start typing your OpenGL code in
and everything will be there for you all
the support stuff that you want like I
am GUI maybe utilities for loading
shaders quickly so that you don't have
to write that open shell code utilities
for debugging all of that kind of stuff
like cameras maybe because you don't
want to just go ahead and make a camera
class you want all of that stuff to be
here already so that what you can do and
what I can do but I make these videos is
just focus on the actual OpenGL code so
this is interesting because it's like
it's almost like the opposite of an
engine right where an engine you would
expect you wouldn't expect to ride any
opengl code at all in an engine you
would expect to just be able to select
the engine to have its own API for you
to be able to be like I want to draw a
triangle I want to draw a rectangle easy
done right but this is like the opposite
because it's like well give me a blank
file for me to literally just type
OpenGL code in that's what I want
because I want to actually type the
OpenGL code myself I just don't want all
the surrounding kind of fluff that you
need like creating a window and like you
know dealing with like events and input
I don't want any of that I just want to
be able to calmly and peacefully write
my OpenGL card and in my case show you
guys the OpenGL card that will make
batch rendering happen for example right
without having to actually you know be
like don't worry about all this other
code of God you know you can like that
death that's a mess right let's start
with a base everyone download this
project and then let's build on top of
that and demonstrate what it is I'm
actually trying to teach and this is
going to become really important in the
future when we like for example learn
about multiple rendering targets
deferred rendering you know physically
based rendering all of these kind of
things you know if you don't have a very
very simple foundation base that you
like or have already built up for
yourself and then you can demonstrate
these concepts on top of that it's gonna
be a huge mess no one's gonna be able to
follow along so that's what inspired
this if you want to hear the Baxter
behind this let's dive in and take a
little bit of a look at what this base
library looks like again I'm gonna
there'll be a link in the description
below to the actual github repository
I expect to probably like I've got some
more ideas for this right like right now
like this isn't even like okay I've done
as much as I can think of let's move on
no I have there this is not finished
there's a few things that I really want
to add and I will do that throughout the
week I might make videos about them if
they kind of video worthy but yeah let's
just take a look at what we've got here
okay so naming wise I've been really
boring it's just called OpenGL core we
kind of have two projects here we have
the core which is almost like the kind
of engine part of it and then we have
sandbox which is like the client right
where you actually write all of your
code if you go to scripts and then this
win pre mag thing you're on this batch
file it will actually generate the
Aveeno studio solution and project at
the moment it's only support Windows but
I'm planning to add Mac and Linux
support as soon as possible in fact you
guys should be able to achieve that
because there's no there's no window
specific coding here at all
so diving into a visual studio what
you'll see here is a few different
projects so we've got glad J love W and
I am going those are kind of like the
dependencies of the support library a
lot of this by the way is inspired like
directly from hazel in fact I've taken
quite a bit of this from hazel so will
be familiar to you but I haven't taken
any of the kind of bigger systems or
anything like that I've just taken
things like layers input you know
logging what else is there yeah I'm
gooey stuff just the whole application
layer orthographic camera and the camera
controllers and again you'll notice
there's no perspective camera or
anything yet that's gonna be definitely
added in the future but we have like
this whole kind of we want OpenGL debug
we've got this whole little library of
card that is really gonna help us with
kind of I guess testing out things or
learning things in OpenGL so that we
have a nice OpenGL sandbox to play
around with so going into here we have
the same kind of setup as what you would
expect inside hazel we have an
application here we push a layer so you
can have more you can have OpenGL card
on multiple layers if you want to that's
totally fine and then inside sandbox
layer which is our example here I've
just written some example card and
you'll note that this sandbox layer file
you know
has OpenGL card in it that's the entire
point the includes are really simple or
we include is GL core dot ancient and if
we want the utilities so in this case
utilities wise I'm using an orthographic
camera controller and shader so this
kind of utility namespace as I call it
is just basically a collection of
helpers for your kind of OpenGL needs so
in other words the shader class here
will just help you with loading a shader
instead of you having to write out all
of that boilerplate OpenGL code yourself
even though this library is about
writing the OpenGL code yourself this
this is just kind of like like a little
utility that will just you know compile
link you know load from text files all
that stuff it'll do all that stuff for
you so that you can just easily call
something like shader you know load from
GLSL files and then it will just give
you that OpenGL shader ID and a lot of
these utilities like this orthographic
camera controller is really just there
to kind of simplify your OpenGL code and
just let you do what you want to do so
in other words again if I wanted to just
try out uniform buffers or something
like that you know I don't want to have
to write a bunch of code to load a
shader to kind of set up my camera so
that I can move around properly make
sure everything's working properly I
don't want any of that I just want to
focus on this specific part of OpenGL
that I want to test out and this library
is really just here to kind of help you
do that that's why we've got like this
whole event system here as well so you
don't have to worry about like input its
everything's kind of handled for you you
can just write your card there's an
online glue render here so you can add
some controls if you want you can really
just do your thing here that's kind of
the whole goal of this library and it's
gonna try and not get into your way too
much so this example that I've set up we
just launched this it's really simple we
just kind of have this Red Square here
we can control the square color via I'm
GUI like that you know we can zoom in
and out with the mouse scroll wheel it's
super simple nothing special at all this
is called the OpenGL sandbox project I'm
probably going to rename this specific
example to like OpenGL example or
examples and then we can build up a
library of examples as well but OpenGL
sandbox specifically my idea for this is
just you have literally this file be
completely blank it'll have all of these
function definitions but in our bodies
so in other words you know we'll have
something like
on the honor - which is when the lair
gets kind of initialized you know we'll
just have empty code like beer so that
you can just jump in and immediately
write your own code that's kind of the
idea but at the moment I've just you
know we've got this pre make file that
generates this whole solution
I haven't split this up into separate
like pre make files per project so that
we can generate multiple solutions one
for each kind of I guess thing that you
want some other words we'd have like an
OpenGL examples solution which will have
like this you know Red Square example so
that you can easily see how to use this
library if you don't know where to start
but then I also want to have an OpenGL
sandbox solution which is just that
blank slate a blank canvas for you to
kind of do all of Europe and Kjell stuff
and in fact I might do that later this
week and I'll make your video probably
talking about how to set up like
multiple pre make files and have that
kind of work together because I haven't
done any pre make videos at all yet and
you can see here that like I'm in this
example it's just looks like 90 lines of
code and it's it's kind of written from
scratch so to speak so there's a bunch
of stuff that this library has done to
obviously help us but the actual
rendering like that's completely inside
this file there's no like renderer or
anything like that it's all this you
know there's a camera controller that we
use there's you know the whole window
system has been abstracted away in the
input and whatever but if we look at the
owner Tash layer you know we Nate we
enable chill debugging which is super
useful you know if we were to
accidentally do something like in this
draw call let's just say I use the
incorrect email my use GL int instead of
unsigned int if I was to launch this the
little debugging system is gonna throw
me an exception I can actually go up
this call stack here and see that it
happened you directly on this line I can
open the log it'll tell me here that
I've used an invalid enum you know we
have this really nice system here that
helps us kind of iron out all of our
opengl errors and make sure that we're
doing everything correctly so that's
what enable GL debugging does then we
have a bunch of open GL it enables then
we have this utility function from GLSL
text files which lets let's lower this
shader or these two shaders just from
text files you can see it's super simple
and then we later use that shader object
in not in an abstract way at all we
literally just use it it just holds that
render ID that unsigned int that we can
then just get
just pump into our other OpenGL
functions so it's super simple and then
you know we create vertex arrays we have
you know a bunch of vertices really
simple stuff here we create a vertex
buffer and an index buffer as well and
set up those attributes and then on
update which is like our render function
you know we clear the screen we Nate you
we bind the shader we get the uniform
location for the view projection matrix
and the color uniform and then we
execute that draw so really simple stuff
it's all done within this file and
that's kind of again the purpose of the
library to just help you actually write
opengl code and not have to worry about
all the fluff that's that kind of stops
you from just diving in and doing what
you want another huge benefit I think to
this is the fact that I'm GUI is just
built in alright and because I'm GUI is
just like built-in for you if I did want
to test something out that would
normally require a lot of setup and like
days or weeks of of actually kind of
building up something like a proper
testbed for myself a proper sandbox to
actually test something out I don't have
to worry about that at all because I can
just add my own GUI controls all around
whatever it is I'm building and I can
have this like great example up and
running within like just no time at all
so I love this I really like something
like I love creating stuff like this
because it really just almost takes the
stress out of being like a Kay you know
I want to learn shadow mapping because
back in the day when I when I was you
know really excited about learning all
of these graphics techniques not that
I'm not now it's just now they're a lot
harder you know now I'm like excited
about learning ray tracing or something
like real time ray tracing something a
bit more advanced but you know back in a
day when I was like ok let's sit down
and write and you know worry about
shadow mapping like that's that's really
difficult to do for someone who's never
done it before and if you're kind of
diving in and doing that just but on
your own with Norris support libraries
with nothing like that it can really be
difficult but you know if I had had you
know I am GUI if I had had like an event
system and this kind of layer system and
this debug system and just this whole if
I had all of that like working and
written down so that I could just you
know look through this and
my OpenGL code and not have to worry
about like you know are but you know
written this engine and it's all
abstract and I have no idea what order
my OpenGL my calls are even coming and
if I don't use something like you know
like a graphics debugger like it it's
it's just a mess right so this will
hopefully help a lot of you people
it'll it's definitely gonna help me
actually teach OpenGL going forward and
in turn teach the game engine series so
I'm super excited about it about it just
let me know what you think in the
comments section below again the link to
download all this code will be in the in
the description below the next video I
put out well I mean the next OpenGL
series video that I put out will use
this library to probably do batch
rendering so we're gonna that's what
that's kind of the first use case of
this I hope you enjoyed the video if you
did please hit that like button don't
forget to help support the channel on
patreon patreon accomplice - the Cherno
huge thank you to everyone at who does
and I will see you guys next time good
bye
[Music]